why
what
way like we're
ooh other show freedom
yeah we will we're well we hey
everyone it's the freedom gang i'm lauren
i'm paul and i'm sky we're here
on this rainy afternoon recording live and
in-person i know your mom and dad
or me and they suck and you
want to have fun ah so here
we have some rainy
nice come in
take some money from your mom and
dad yeah and brandy yes yeah please
just send bring it to your liberal
friends you can't get money through the
mail you're gonna come your person give
us that money oh yeah you can't
send money through the mail you shouldn't
i mean you shouldn't yeah my grandmother
always
five dollars on my birthday course i
don't see them miller be a car
yeah but i remember if i ever
had to send money my my mother
was always like put rapid and paper
at least like paper around it so
no one yells you're going to get
the security envelopes yeah it was one
time where my grandma sent you can't
see
through them oh like who twenty five
dollars in a card for and i
was living in new york and i
was really broken i twenty five in
the card went missing i didn't get
to know and and i saw your
allying know sh but she was really
concerned about being gone and she was
like really upset that it was lost
in the mail yeah
and i was really upset because i
really wanted twenty five dollars and i
was like somebody took it now and
ah that it stressed me out dan
and you never got it and never
did yeah yeah she didn't send you
another twenty five dollars she didn't know
no i would have a decent thing
to do would be to send you
another what a nice would've been nice
also
she could've been lying about how much
money was in there well that's true
for what missing it could have been
she could yeah there might have been
no money in there there might have
been a card because yeah what if
she's lying twenty five dollars is an
odd amount this is weird especially because
twenties come out of the well i
think it was because ah she would
you ever had a little money yeah
but but sent for
yeah no she didn't have forty so
she wasn't just sending twenty huge amounts
everywhere now see this is actually interesting
i recently heard a story about someone
finally finally we do something this show
actually interested was wow learned about the
amount received no i don't talk about
this because i feel like do you
really think oh that's a weird amount
like you i don't think i don't
think there's any weird
i'ma i wouldn't care so gave me
fifty nine dollars i'm like is you
yes if you got that money in
that in that situation of course i
would have been like oh fucking thing
fifty three so awesome or twenty five
yeah it's just a weird thing to
be like i'm going to send twenty
five dollars i guess they didn't open
your wallet and you have a twenty
year of a five i guess i'll
put that how
does that yes because people read every
damn day relative high end money it
would be like a single you would
get a single bill right yeah yeah
sure denominate one to ah i used
to get two dollar bills sure i
will have tons of two dollar bills
like my i have ever stack do
you really yes they used to give
them out as change at universal
studios why because i think parking was
eighteen dollars yes today would give that
we've talked about yeah we yeah like
hell i probably said that my family
members are bills i have a lot
of schiller bills it's a it's a
tradition let's stop doing the show we
a two dollar bill we've talked about
it because you talked about but i
think we were saying about
yeah it was two dollars difference but
was there some about three dollars i
don't think that that was three dollars
or eight hundred to one nine years
were used okay until they release a
three dollar bill i want more weird
currency what strange currents it's weird that
they they only go up to one
hundred is considering with ah inviting circulation
yeah in circulation but cah
considering how high inflation is now and
how like no one ever uses the
one like no one ever uses coins
anymore did you feel like when they
got a new one he's out it's
not true they'll seem weird there's just
no point there's still paying a parking
meters where you have to that is
true and that's fucked up and i
also think that there are too many
places that don't accept cash now i
think that's elitist yes
yeah i think there's also like like
laundromats and stuff a lot of them
you still have to use coin using
ct axis of annoying but but i
guess what i'm trying to say is
it's what with inflation and like no
one uses pennies well legislation let's just
say that and nichols were on their
way to your question let me tell
you times i think they're not long
for this world as we've i love
it to coins
are problematic yeah but but they're my
fave but yeah i like the problem
animal i'm liking how more places are
having the app thing for for paying
for parking but i think that that's
also it's only problem because i think
what even just if you're old and
you don't know how to use an
axe you have to finish it always
download the ash always been an op
option yeah yeah but i guess like
may start making a two hundred dollar
bill because you know start making it
start start i would love obama i'd
love to more build some weird bills
i'd like a seventy five dollar bill
i think that would feel really good
that would feel good seventy five would
be one that looks so pretty because
hundreds are like bragging yeah hundreds let's
him benjy
omens yeah but a seventy five where
you're like here keep the chain put
some dork on the seventy five dollar
bills sound like bragging who should it
be ted cruz ted cruz
here's a cruise
let me slip you here's a couple
teddies
people uncle daddy yeah well that's nice
guys okay at that point a couple
teddies couple of times i think grandma
sadako hey rocky i'm gonna put putting
any spin on this oh yeah eighty
two dollar bill but both of them
next to each other and say who's
your favorite so i can vote on
each pitch
we're gonna make we're going to make
a bill hey rain on it which
is going to be the best bill
we ever had to tell me when
the best pills ever whoa we're going
to have teddy rocks going to be
a special pity ruckman teddy rocks it's
gonna be gross because hey here they're
gonna be for me it's gonna be
full you're going to have their arms
with me it's really afford a three
dollar bill and they're going to be
kissing and it's gonna be so good
to me like we're the best it's
gonna change
ultimately change economy
what if he's dead by the time
it comes out oh no sounds sony
respectful yeah i don't know how teddy
expands like he's getting to be like
he's probably thirty five and it really
is a long ruck spins live though
but yeah i just heard the lifespan
of a rock spinous thirty eight oh
no almost there i know
but he's still youthful that's the thing
as long as he keeps at it
and like in the public eye he'll
probably live past did you take the
picture of the oldest golden retriever know
she's like she's like twenty two or
something like that you know only white
face i loved her so there was
this video that was like this service
dog it meets its favor
brate animal at disney world and it
was a service dog dressed as snow-white
meeting tigger the like castanets person this
and i was like in like manner
that comment was like it was like
people magazine was like this is everything
i was like this is not nothing
everything they all know what's happening the
dog meets it's favourite character then the
character comes out
out and the dog jumps into like
after the sky after it's been like
poked in the bud tigger pets the
dog and then the dog jumps into
it like what oh my god i'm
tearing into sounds is everything
oh jag
everything i really want brands to stop
talking like teenage i hate i hate
when brand say i hate when brands
on social media speak in the first
person yeah i'll comment on some like
netflix will comment something like i love
this i'm like you yeah yeah you
love this netflix
um i love that they're always like
a year out of date with sly
yeah yeah oh yeah um do you
think was it by the way like
posters are now being used for emphasis
you're pointing
do you think that is it like
could it have been like that gumby
where the guy dresses up as gumby
because the dog loves the gumby toy
so like maybe maybe there was more
to it i'd that's an amazing i'll
tell you i didn't even finish watching
that's why i was like maybe they
pointed all of the edge i don't
care you've seen the gumby video i've
seen doubly so that the dog was
a toy
toy of gumby and then the entire
setup like a dad dresses up like
a giant gumball and their dog is
so happy because it's a combination of
everything like obviously you can smell it
says yes his dad it's danny tell
it to doing grumpy i don't know
if you have a dog or you
are the parent
of the dog yeah of course he
can i somehow big i honestly don't
think that if like a giant really
made a connection between that being the
same as his toy if a giant
you don't think he can i maybe
you can if a giant gumby came
down back stomped through the ceiling but
he's still excited i don't know if
i look up and say like oh
that's gumby i think honestly
feels like that dog did know yeah
i don't think every dog would know
i think the thing that i think
the digest basically show you drunk fish
because i think i get your wish
there was another video that i saw
of a little fat baby dressed as
winnie winnie the pooh costume yeah and
then they're at disneyland and this little
fat baby sitting there and the like
from you
i just see the bait from the
back and then there's winnie the pooh
um it the guy in the costume
poorly and you honestly don't know you
don't know they won't you have to
do a cross check and i've begged
them to tell me um and then
the winnie the pooh turns around and
sees the little baby dresses oh ooh
oh
oh and the little baby like is
so excited that this moment is happening
like turns and like to whoever like
mom or dad and like it's fucking
happen oh my gosh
go into noticing it's so adorable that's
so q i shall thousand times because
the winnie the pooh like stops his
tracks like oh yeah am i looking
in a little room that's amazing but
sounds like yeah i think so hey
everybody he sounds to do the show
huh
ah the hey paul notes
i mean over ah it's really raspy
i was just watching the ball the
whole box that's my group bother i'm
winnie the fucking pooh father were out
though oh that's good thank you hey
that's the title oh bother where art
thou that's that's we go we did
a a house that we meet that
the
title and we are trying to disfigure
were trying to get there yeah and
it makes sense every three mm episode
is where we have the title first
well like so josh who doesn't work
on the show anymore sends us a
title traitor yeah judas yeah but he's
still sends his titles because he's cool
because you're listening the episodes he doesn't
know what the fuck we're talking about
he sends a title in advance and
yeah we've get our way there and
then we have to put it in
there
yeah and he's causing more trouble than
he's helping when he's not helping matter
producer matt producer needs help desperately because
he is in the weeds he gets
really oh my god he gets so
he's drenched in transportation for winner yeah
we lost this last episode what did
he sent it and the threesome theme
song was so low my
god and and it was like get
your shit together and then someone had
to be like hey ah the theme
song hi i'm slow i think was
july was like ah so i was
like oh hey you might wanna ah
oh my god you guys everybody calling
a party whoa nice laid back
guevara thought i was gonna fall i
feel like flew into my girls like
a foreign object what's your shirt lapel
it's a little it's a little um
fuckin ladybug oh me straighten my life
from me ah the rodney dangerfield movie
yeah cool if my shirt is based
on that movie it's a little like
soccer orange crowing
across the table like the girlfriend i
thought it was like an alu
i'm from wing rated r rated r
selected renew radar he would say it
so
right all you'd ever get oh my
god i miss movie phone i used
to have to pull over because you
you'd go to a movie theater know
i miss it i didn't miss that
oh oh yeah you just miss it
i miss having it i missed that
era of america you would go to
a movie theater the movie i sold
out yeah you wanted to see and
so you'd have to like pull over
on the side of the road where
a paved
phone was and then like call moviefone
to find a different theater that it
was playing oh my god wow you
mean how did we live through that
i was like oh usually hold myself
and so did my personal my five
and then if you want to listen
if you want to watch a movie
that was like start with have actually
got away from florida every single movie
trades with tax man to get to
the braided on
are my favorite of course before i'll
say it again my favorite that i
ever heard him do was you have
selected midnight in the garden of good
and evil wow what now it did
he emphasised every words did he record
recording edward in the universe and they
just put it together oh for the
idols no
no just really just write the dictionary
so this really were aardvark ever so
zebra oil oh we gotta find this
guy because it's like every yeah whatever
happened to him but just absolutely adored
i used to listen to him all
the time where are you mr moviefone
ms sonia around there in the middle
of talking
something you were doing so by board
myself to tears yeah mr moviefone i'm
gonna look you up but but ah
russ leatherman huh russ leatherman movie huh
here's a video you have searched for
russ leatherman here's a video of russ
leatherman supposedly
i never want to know what he
looks like i've never seen him yeah
and i don't want to know
um let's see what we have here
is this it is it no i'm
not fuck are you doing i don't
know this fucking fuck are you doing
what the member sue simmons i don't
well rusty video so good is it
sue simmons scratch lady local news lady
new york and they're going to they're
going to break
and then as it fades from her
at the desk to the video you
hear her she's looking at someone off
camera then you hear her say the
fuck are you doing i've seen wow
finally classic classic of the genre by
the way the the news bloopers did
you watch him this year i've not
watched the news bloopers this year they're
not good this
there was really only one that was
any good maybe the news got too
good i feel like either people are
too good at the news or you
just it's one of those things which
that was good when there was fifteen
years of buildup it's gotta be like
the olympics yeah it's like it's only
special because it's every four years yeah
yeah yeah you know to find your
favorite movie just called movie phone it's
not
the movie that's oh we used elected
is playing at the arrowtown okay this
is a video like this it starts
with a commercial
i was putting this little girl and
wipe away and i have a question
chat here is here he is why
he's excited that it starts in philadelphia
current movies bryce to tim talking now
he started doing the voice you so
he's glad i orleans he's got annoyed
voice we would yeah when you started
wait well how's doing and then you
told me to stay know but i
was
an excited movies would you put your
zip code yeah and then sudan he
was reading a million fucking things he
must have because how could it possibly
work i know i mean there's so
many i guess you knock your chains
out right and yeah we'll use you
also like so he's already recorded every
around the country
time he's already recorded the tiny records
every possible movie title oh and the
mediator okay and then they just put
the combinations okay you have selected this
it's playing at but i'm like useless
you can utilize every location well he's
already amc but one time he's yeah
one time my god here we go
remember yeah guy no recall
voting booths and he had no handbook
so i was elected live because i
was the elected slaves of new york
so they couldn't find anyone oh and
welcome to claims of new york the
classic cramer but so he just so
he was just being humble and saying
it was down to me and one
other asshole and i sucked less than
he did and that's
i got it yeah man it's not
all the same just other guys sucks
i mean it's not nice but also
to say someone like donald and i'm
sorry he got pretty far sounding like
that he was in the booth with
you also his voice also donald duck
is famous yeah that second voice everyone
knows it's amazing i'm always doing really
funny exactly how i've changed
i guess i'd take you to party
that sounds like you're being possessed
but his voice is just normal and
then he puts on a movie phone
like accent i don't know yeah russ
leatherman alright i'm ready to go what's
the right everybody here we go jason
x jason goes to hell
zila come back i know it can
still there canonically here if you're religious
scholars say that jason is still in
hell he doesn't deserve that any awesome
beds like hell purgatory maybe if anybody
deserves it it's chastened don't you think
no
you think jason should just do a
thousand years berkeley they go to winchester
we talk about jay
jason and the argonauts you don't think
okay nevermind
ah
could not think of a famous
like the ones we know mizuki warner
of course jason bateman yeah or he
should go to i don't think of
his name is being jason it's sometimes
when you have things like georgia names
because his sister is just you know
i just mean nine it's like jason
big time i'm not making it safe
payment jason bateman all right we need
to take a break okay
hammer back and by the way this
um
movie phone video vandal oh so this
video it's on facebook or so i
don't know how i got but it's
got two comments
one says as for tether
what does that mean tenser i don't
know you have selected ezra taser read
it or the other and that was
from fifty one weeks ago fifty one
weeks ago almost a year and this
one is one year
von dutch
oh my god and was the video
uploaded his one year ago wow
ah well you should leave a ca
three point six thousand view i wasn't
yes i don't know how to tell
okay and can you oh december seventeen
twenty twenty weird so a one year
ago people looked at people looked at
it and said hey guys nothing further
to i think we should owe everyone
who's listening should find this video what's
it called
mr movie phones russ leatherman iconic vip
voices find this and then comment either
von dutch or advertising yeah we'll see
why or some other two word thing
fly either from a brand name yeah
yeah proctor and gamble yeah maybe don't
do von dutch because then they might
start deleting hazards hazardous i'll give you
this one pink chips
i'll give you one two mothers love
oh scott i'm sorry i'm looking up
advertiser any two words i see a
math teacher math teacher okay math teacher
from the new york city department of
education we probably shouldn't be talking about
real people we know there's somebody trying
to tag as a tesla like hey
you're a movie phone fan you gotta
check
yeah maybe maybe they're trying to tag
von dutch as well hey von dutch
you should sponsor this guy no but
as her taser isn't clickable i don't
know anyway it sounds like a um
tony lister is registering taser kisan click
desert isn't clickable i didn't do seven
new broadway musical sounds like gossip to
me did you hear as her tether
isn't clickable isn't clickable oh my god
i'm sorry to be a bitch but
ezra taser isn't clicking sounds like dairy
of a wimpy kid like as her
tether isn't clickable isn't it's like you
can't get into it click and so
he's like suffer
oh what else did i wrote if
it wouldn't be good it's ah no
it's a book and it's like people
found your diaries from like last year
and published oh and you're like anne
frank's diary yeah you're the wimpy lodge
burned you shit rose to dress she
died even a little kid is about
a little wimpy kid goes to school
and has a diary i don't freaking
know
just a pussy like this everything so
woke
i check on the vagina
oh did you ever want to do
huh i got asked to do it
once i can remember what the context
was but i said knew i forgot
just yeah they said can you just
make a talking fish um no i
like was asked to do ah that
at some point and i was like
the idea of me doing this but
isn't it literally it's like a pill
yeah it yeah
rita you perform a monologue but i'm
like i i don't want to show
that doug benson did was the marijuana
marijuana logs it was tony cami arj
barker and tony camino yeah it was
yeah yeah yeah any ran for a
while yeah and they published it was
off-broadway does he still smoke weed yes
i can confirm guys can confess
i'm not sure about tony nor arch
are just so funny pregnancy margin a
million i mean i him leaving australia
he lives on a shirt he opened
for the flight of the concorde when
they were out at the creek and
i was like oh got him to
the greek they got him sick but
it was funny because i was like
oh i wonder how he's going to
do because no one's expected because i
don't think he was building or whatever
he did a half hour
was so funny and so sounds really
fun i was just like madly funny
what a craftsmen he's great they're out
there they're the people who would do
what they do well they're never understand
when people do something so mean it's
a mystery to me how do you
do a thing and then also be
good at it i cannot imagine i
don't care i love
was there like a show a play
lorne that you really want to do
like you're like oh i would love
to play this part someday
i remember well i remember in high
school i we they were doing noises
off and i i audition and i'm
sure tony sure i'm sure i had
a horrible edition but i would have
loved to have been in that because
it's really fun but then they canceled
the whole play for some reason thinking
wow they pivoted did something completely different
um but right now is there a
play i don't know i just yeah
i don't know or like something i
think something fun like that with physical
comedy and sort of slept i finally
saw that for the first time a
few years ago theme layer the the
play yeah i'd never seen it and
i think that you see a good
version where it's like yeah it was
really fun yeah it was really fun
yeah yeah this i don't know that
the movie is any good but i
watched the movie afterwards i mean
just a day later i liked the
movie but i was also fifteen so
you know i mean it's like my
face was probably a horrible oh no
you are stupid but when that's happening
right in front of you yeah yeah
yeah everything turns around and yeah really
funny it's yeah look and you like
the prior eyelids open yeah they put
you in that contraption and then put
the drops in your eye and then
damage rise for life yeah but you
still can't look away from anything which
is kinda cool then they show footage
of like the atomic bomb and hitler
yeah really sold yeah it's so good
um i have my favorite tv show
o r i've never seen that movie
by the way which one clockwork aren't
oh no sounds good oh we should
do is it just got scene i
like it
yeah well you know honestly haven't seen
in thirty years now do the sky
hasn't seen episodes have a guest who
also hasn't seen it sometimes yeah yeah
we take all comers
um was going to want new year's
resolution going if yeah about yeah well
i'm reading books and i'm feeling very
good about it oh yeah you're two
weeks a month i've already read a
month or one a week well it's
it's twenty four total and for a
year i've read i read in the
shade one into the new year so
i count that starting but i also
have
i'm on my i'm on my third
book whoa which ones have you read
i read um such a fun age
by kylie read which was really great
and i loved that i've heard of
it i read a heart that works
by rob delaney oh yeah i was
told not to read it it's it's
really devastating but it's really beautiful yeah
i really want to read it he's
um he's a really great right
checks when that when that book came
out and it was all over social
media people were talking about a tech
board and they said what if i
started a backlash against romney yeah
i'm saying it's not all that
this book is okay it's really so
good and then i um i am
reading i'm glad my mom died by
oh yeah how is it oh it's
really good yeah okay yeah i'm on
i'm having a great month reading every
book has been great her stories while
yeah it's choosing early on the comedy
gaming television show oh yeah yeah she
was really
fun to work with and then i
was just walking down the street one
day and she like yelled at me
from her cards
used to maybe it was three months
ago so my name is griffin newman
but i'm really enjoying her book it's
cool yeah read see martin's book um
another for christmas yeah just came out
the one went number one walking that
one knows that way i knew all
too graphic novels it's like half a
graphic wow was that it's going yeah
i mean no idea nice thing it's
a lot of comics very slight like
yeah didn't forty five minutes right remain
but it's very good yeah it's like
his
studying dams in in the movie in
his writing career okay and then and
then like he got famous yeah it's
like a famous bangla chicks so it's
like rich it's one page yeah i'm
a little hurt yeah
um i read his standup book and
it sounds good i love that oh
my god it was great it was
great yeah how was the flight fucking
smooth yeah just gotta say smooth really
sweet paul every director my did you
get your rants your resolutions no good
to get peanuts i haven't had a
chance to start yet on the things
that i want to do further things
it's still hard to talk about it
it's still very early but i um
yeah the year started busy like i
have a lot of well the year
oh my car died oh jeff's funeral
yeah i buried it which was a
pain in the ass
six feet under just for something that
big just barely wow
but yeah though that was a real
drag as well so do you have
a chapter in the new year i'm
getting my new car thursday what are
you getting i'm getting what's your license
plate number and e electric version of
those the same thing oh wow guys
so very excited about that oh great
i got a high-brow i've literally driven
at ten miles wow in six months
right now because i've been running clubs
because neither of us have to leave
at the same time anymore because someone
say now it does change things up
a bit
yeah it's such a bummer i got
this brand new car and then a
baby comes you really can't even drive
fucking drive it while you throw the
baby around the car on the car
or drive the baby around like a
car yeah jellybean look wheels
you know my my resolution of just
like getting back into the exercise thing
is just itself fucking hard yeah figure
one so i start i cannot exercise
the way i have a real messy
bed messy head thing going on right
now yes i was and am a
messy bitch yeah took a dna test
yeah that's right yeah
yeah it was more specific than the
first one yeah yeah first year that
bitch then i was that messy bitch
yeah um where there's like i took
down the decorations inside the house and
they're just honored dining table yeah because
the thing that they're contained in is
in the garage and it's been all
wet and rainy so
yes twenty is an ideal to do
it so the wishes of things have
like taking down the decorations no i
did not count that as a resolution
that would be yeah the bar is
wake up every day yeah that actually
we are on like challenging organizing cat
grade on like yeah getting rid of
stuff it feels so good i'm trying
to be one of my goals i
have done that yeah yeah so that's
good i just dropped off five bags
at goodwill felt amazing yeah my clothes
are just exploding and i'm like i
don't
need this stuff and i also have
to say i've been renting clothes from
this company and if they want to
sponsor three-time i would love yeah we
were if i'm newly and you you
l y and it's really fun because
you a little u l y yes
newly and i'm really i'm really enjoying
them on my third month now and
i'm like oh are you have you
rented what you're wearing right now no
i don't
i have a bag yet it's coming
on wednesday will you rent it to
me ah you wanna buy borrow these
clothes you should rent your clothes while
your retina yeah guys other people i
make the money to pay some rocky
yeah but i just wouldn't throw it
out there because i love shopping and
i'm finding that it's like kind of
making me feel like i went shopping
but i don't care if i
get sick of this thing i don't
really end up liking them i just
send it back i mean sometimes it's
great it feels really good at my
closet doesn't get overflowing with stuff that
i end up not really wearing i
found things with tags when i was
organizing and i'm like i feel like
such a jerk such a bed feel
i hate that one company that i
bought things from takes things back three
hundred and sixty five days like afterwards
yes wow i'm getting back two hundred
dollars i was just sitting in my
closet
i never wore and i'm so excited
it's like that it's easy and everyone
should be like that yeah i was
gonna give you two hundred dollars i
just thought i'd be nice like a
new year goes you make your children
and twenty five dollars because no weird
projected that
oh do you ever get the this
is the problem for me is that
you when things get too chaotic in
the house there's just shit all over
the place and it's like okay well
in order to do to clean this
up i gotta clean this up yes
oh but actually mike found the cigarette
this whole video of that it's like
from malcolm in the middle um what's
his name the dad from
brene brown yeah dan he um he's
like going to fix me so when
i saw this video oh yes oh
another squeaking i mean yeah yeah yeah
let me get the oil for that
although it was time to go to
the store it's like a whole thing
yes we he might feels he related
like when things are like a bunch
of things that are half done yeah
it's maddening yeah it's maddening and it's
like hey doesn't need to daily talk
about that where
thing up on in a weird place
in his kitchen or something like that
like bothered him for years and years
and years and then one day he
just like went up there and took
it off and he was like i
haven't done this six years ago does
so oh my god and it's like
it feels like that sometime in we
have that with a window recently where
i just looked at it
and every single time i was in
that room i looked at i was
like god gotta take care of it
god take care of it then one
day you just do and it feels
great i know we're kind of doing
a lot of those things now it
feels really just the one where the
guy died
the underwear guy died what
is this the wonder where the guy
died did you hear me sam i
heard you say is this the wonder
where the guy dies just the window
where the guy was supposed to fix
it any dive oh yeah yeah oh
my god he died jumping up a
window of on the first floor
so he runs out and dive rolled
and then he killed himself yeah he
rolled right into the street and a
big trucking
mayo
the sound of a big truck going
fifty five miles an hour remaining emily
just went down you have selected dive
and roll
that um so no they're not going
good lauren we need you to hold
our feet to the fire i need
everyone to do a little bit more
just a little bit more i don't
want to disappoint you know i'm not
i'm not killing it at all friends
i'm just reading books that's the only
thing i've really but that's the one
i i said the most i cared
about and that's doing ah i'm also
i'm try
going to locate the golden voice to
homeless man so that's taking up a
lot i'm like oh didn't tannoy day
doesn't he own u t h he's
on day was chocolate rain sorry what
didn't he what does he own youtube
yea i thought that like that voice
like i was like
oh yea they gave them like his
own radio show and he can climb
to the top of the charts i
heard like he was doing well as
a result of all that and then
he like fell off the wagon and
he got scared roger that so you've
been trying to find him trying to
track him down remember searching for sugar
man which i'd ever watched what was
this sub
documentary about some musician they saw it
yeah but what's that one where zach
galifianakis was the documentary miss yang over
between two ferns movie
he interviewed no it's not this woman
with his charming see like helps out
um she's like an housed oh well
she's not with us anymore but yeah
his oh i don't know if she
was quite old um i don't remember
it was called like queen duvet being
smarter about it i just knew yeah
yeah and then he's in it and
he like you know bizer match
address or something i remember he sets
up an apartment yeah yeah memories that
he helped her for awhile that was
very kind yeah well you know he's
a kind guy he's a good guy
who people he doesn't know wow
he is the worst person to know
if you don't know him great you'll
get a better treat huh
so what what are you going to
do in order to make sure that
paul and i do i guess yeah
i'm gonna just keep asking you every
week on the show and it's gonna
be more and more nursing more than
that i need a consequence so you
are prepared for to get more and
more embarrassing where we will not have
done the thing yes okay embarrassing for
you or no i won't be embarrassed
honest i go in to bora i'll
start to get embarrassed to ask i
guess but oh still huh
i think that'll be the best way
to do it yeah i guess to
me it yeah you we need something
more we need like a friend to
come in and act okay because i
didn't depend um i'm gonna say you
know what i should do this would
really work for you i think you
have to get a panicked phone call
from casey wilson telling you if you
don't
completely new year's resolution think more what's
going to happen you have to do
this because i do everything casey wilson's
yes exactly exactly
okay if you send this friend to
us they i feel like what would
help motivate me as if they sing
you've got a friend in me from
toy story okay so i'm sen tom
hanks to sing it as woody i'm
i need to redo it as buzz
i wanna know he's without randy newman
i think god really yeah tom hanks
doing a randy newman impression
thanks guys your friend in me i
feel like we could get him to
do this yeah just send him a
type he posted that he needed one
blog one it's like yeah money yeah
he's gonna do that right yeah yeah
don't do this but we didn't advise
to you oh what's everyone nervous but
so he's taking my son i was
think you've done this
get him a typewriter yeah well because
he love seeing collects vintage i know
he does oh it's like leprechaun rules
like if you send him a typewriter
he has to do yeah yeah yeah
does he have a typewriter room in
his house it must be out of
control this ah i must know i
think he has to look you would
want to have him all over the
house because then i would think they're
offsite he's got a like maybe it's
like an office
us where there's a wall of typewriters
there was a guy definitely has that
that seems good there was a guy
when i went to acting school you
just won there's one guy it was
said no one and that's why you
loved it no but he and when
you would go there the housing situation
was there weren't really any single apartments
or one bedroom amar
shipments so everyone pretty much like when
you move there you would sometimes they
would facilitate like oh you're you know
we've found you a two bedroom apartment
and this person is going to be
a roommate or whatever so everyone had
roommates basically simply everyone had unless you
moved into like an like i did
an old lady's house for awhile now
not weird at all yeah by law
walls
the walls bad ronald subway there
but this one guy scratching this one
guy moved into like the pretty excited
because this is where i live too
the in the village green these kind
of pretty expensive apartments and he didn't
have a roommate and he and he
had a party at his place once
he was like oh let me show
you my office and he like
his second bedroom he had a vintage
typewriter in there and a desk and
we were like what how can you
afford to live here that's weird yeah
and but whose original typewriter how can
you afford this because he has massive
costs ten delors but he was just
like spending hundreds and hundreds of
dollars a month just to have some
peopwe typewriter in his apartment some people
like to make it look like something's
happening some people call me the space
cowboy
but not body
i wish people would get it again
on the same page some people call
me maurice okay cover the gangster revolves
so high because i came all call
you so many things i think they
should call you paul i wish they
would that's my name my mommy sorry
space cowboy
i'm sorry gangster of love i'm spaced
out oh thank you sir love was
gonna be late i'm the gangster of
love sorry your you kingstone a little
bit of heavy luggage mr lowe said
call me maurice so we will win
alright we have cigarettes
we're back
i've just decided on a three i
love it and i don't want i
more he said you're ready no theory
was gonna tell us yeah but no
no we're just back into the what
is it what's up man hey hey
guys what's on your mind what's going
on leaves me wanna talk about this
you could do right now he's got
you've got that look you have a
look like you wanna play game i
really want to tell you about this
three cheer that i just found okay
listen this is
is submitted by michael pier c and
it's kyle's that's called call of old
it's cold it's cold that's not how
grandpa tells it
okay so we improvise a two minute
scene of something relatively boring great guy
of he's just played the first part
of the show and then after two
minutes
after two minutes someone says that's not
how grandma tells it ah then we
do the same scene again but everything
is exaggerated and over dramatic like the
way as this is what michael pearson
says the way a stupid old man
would tell a story she's right yeah
affect your soul back to your exactly
we will do this though alright
yeah absolutely
we will mock yielded only because whoever
told us to so maybe for god's
name are you guys ready to do
that's not how grandpa toe and who
wants to say that's not how grandpa
tells it i'll say you sam yeah
i want paul to okay thank you
thanks for endorsing my
campaign great alright are you ready yeah
here we go two minutes
well you know so it all started
because the rain was pouring down and
i wish it would pour up sometime
i know but then so what happened
was this this like the sort of
like parade of dogs kind of came
through and they were like mania things
it was like a literal parade or
it was just you're saying per
parade like there were a bunch of
dogs
we're just a bunch of dogs there's
a bunch of yeah i'll just a
mundane bunch of dogs yeah what is
so weird that dogs all hang out
together
they got set loose i don't know
and it was one from like a
dog nose one note here's what about
a broken was one dog that was
lost in the neighborhood there was a
sign up for months yeah it was
pouring rain yeah this dog came running
down the street it had like ah
no collar and some people you know
grabbed put in their car and that's
i
think how they got it back i
don't know how they even found out
who are they addressing the dogs the
people yeah i think they put on
like dog years to try to get
it's attention or some like yeah just
try to finish
this makes sense are we doing what
most i don't think so i think
i don't know i mean it too
yeah but but i thought we were
telling a story i don't know where
guys doing the scene oh okay but
when you start telling the story it
made sense to me i know i'm
gonna i'm gonna start
ah ok
hey lauren what's memories hello whoo
um are you gonna say guitar
now i'm gonna give it to one
of you what i've decided that it
would give me more pleasure i want
you to prepare to buy this tsar
ah i've decided that it would go
good guy i was prepared to buy
this guitar i wanted to buy it
too so one of you wants to
buy you don't know if you're going
to give it for free doing guess
i feel i would feel guilty just
taking your time how are we gonna
share i just said well i would
well i was gonna have a contest
if you can guess how many jellybeans
are in my pocket then i'll give
you the guitar if you can't guess
by the way it's a it's a
number between one and two
one point five
god it's your chest guess you can
well she got it right off the
bat well that's right i kind of
jelly bean in half their sweet i
listen to this cool beat do do
do do do you like this
that is a sick guitar beat my
friend of se
it remind me of seinfeld do you
remember mr moviefone yeah yeah i do
recall that episode by the way i'm
an agent a music agent i wanna
put you on stage you are a
mutant night unite your amusing cajun and
amusing cajun and i wanna put you
in
form all
you're gonna make fun of my accent
that's not original ram but tells us
it's not yet eighteen sec is why
seconds ago oh it's so oh well
anyways it was time anyway she's already
we're talking graduations i want to put
you on stage tonight as the new
lead guitars for the red hot chili
but can i try out my song
yeah b v d the knee
that feat that i love a beat
ah okay yes huh oh too many
see no so long sometimes
hi hi lauren hi stop it we
but then i thought grandpa lap oh
right lorin come on over here hey
marie's is good to see your bow
wow are you going to sell your
guitar are you gonna do ah a
big show for us right now home
hold on hold on hold on i
like to offer you a one million
dollars i'd like to offer you my
first born ramzan a berita both of
those sound really good guys but i've
decided because i'm so stupid i'm going
to give you a guitar wow hey
but we wanted to pay police to
me
million dollars i'll do whatever you want
ah i'll do anything i'll drive your
car cross country full of all the
stuff you want to get rid of
no way how is this to be
settled rain i'm going to give it
to who ever can guess how many
jelly beans are in my pocket ah
let me guess you have one million
general bands oh well
all narrowed down for you it's a
number between one and two a hundred
and twenty nine i'm a woman
look maurice you got the inside track
on this just guess anything you'll be
closer nor between one or two-way it
is it a magic number that no
one has discovered yet i'm sorry you're
closer oh no i didn't want to
win was unaware it was that to
exit i don't know how to play
it because i'm a stupid woman
grandpa you're so sexist grab my free
sexes look here's your guitar now lay
down one of your beats okay do
get good buddy
hey i'm a music agent yeah i
know and i wanna give you any
soiling cover of rolling stone going hello
cousin hold on one cousin i'm calling
my cousin marvin berry hey marva new
units that sound you're looking for a
sound like these and i think that
beat the beat
that i need that bebe also ah
tell you
well we did it i don't feel
like we did i mean we did
we did do it i just don't
know if that's what it let's try
this let's try to tell lesser one
more we'll tell him the eight extremely
boring story okay we'll do an extremely
boring scene alright and then we'll amp
okay right this reminds me of when
harry
this dallas harris whittles did
carl's junior for the first time where
he was like i just want to
come on and do the most boring
character
his name is control situ couldn't help
himself yeah make it funny alright alright
i was just thinking i'm on the
way here yeah good things yeah
alright here we go
just thinking terrible things here
hi
alright so you have fifteen overdue library
books between the two of you um
yeah i have seven i know i'm
really sorry about that i've eight outstanding
books i just got i was in
the hospital for a little bit i
broke my leg yeah and there were
some complications so i had to stay
a little guy worth ten cents a
book a day and i got lost
it's okay it's ten cents a book
a day can and it's been fifty
days right and you have eight books
and you have seven yeah we were
the best phones we we got them
on the same day so yeah well
it's not so because it was there
was that book about how to stay
friends there was another book about what
it's gonna show you if you loved
him
yeah yeah would i just go through
a friend how to ideal you got
all of them and honestly our whole
friend section is empty and that way
you have a great friend section we
did really well i think you haven't
questioned the bile and we've had them
for fifth so there's a bunch of
kids over there includes i don't know
how to make a friend ah it
does include sundays because you can drop
them in the bin
the kids are crying because they came
here to get those books to learn
how to make a friend and then
they don't they don't have any books
and they don't know how to make
a friend so they're kind of not
in touch with each other and what
is the solution corners like because i
feel like we're talking about the problem
problem problem with blah blah so i
have to pay it all at once
i wouldn't say i'm rich touring the
books today and pay now we don't
have the books
we lost my throat burn it wasn't
real burp it was my throat burt
what's the difference between a real burp
and your throat well like a real
bird you kind of like ah like
a therapy was like a sound your
throat makes it just like in there
spacer yeah yeah because the stroke comes
through cool like barbed it was like
a throat quiff my
my throat opened up like a vagina
right yeah so what's what's so we
don't have the books we don't have
the money what do you want to
do you don't have the books you
know on the money no yeah sorry
sorry okay what do you want to
do
that's not how grandpa terrell shit
hey shh you're in the library no
screaming sorry look only i could talk
loudly we got a problem um you
know how at the library you're supposed
to return the books that you take
out yeah i asked what's sweet heart
we ain't got um okay you too
wet bandits need to look at my
files here
or you owe me one million dollars
in book fees calls merely tell me
if we rob a bank to to
pay it off oh that's a great
idea rather you should go right now
like ragas do it right now because
i need this money now let's rob
the librarian okay she takes pickup off
he was all your money huh look
we painted them books in the ground
to grow a book tree it ain't
happened yet but i have a faith
that we yes here's my collection of
dimes from people paying for their late
books link link link link owl these
times hurtling revenge times wow wow wow
this adds up
two almost one billion nine hundred and
ninety nine thousand nine hundred and ninety
nine dollars we just need ten more
dimes could get get ten more damage
that's three more blink thinking see it
happening thinking la rota did it here
you go here's a million dollars five
hundred x i'm so stupid
hey hey what you need to believe
in yourself more no i don't know
how i'm scared this book about how
to make a friend and you could
be our friends but a little bit
a little bit read the whole thing
i love murphy
i can't believe we're all married to
each other
it really was a slippery slope it
grandpa that's such a dumb story
we did it we did do it
well we have thirteen seconds no we
don't but we don't that's unlucky that's
unlucky whoa alright go oh wow see
that's how i think we did it
right i think we did a writers
don't think this they're all times they
were right arm i think it's possible
to do it right the game is
flawed no i don't think the game
is flawed i think the players are
fighting players are definitely thankfully but you
can't give us a flawed game and
expect flawed players to do it totally
how do they use flaw don't give
us a flock game and expect flawed
players to make a plot and scene
don't leave law was a flawed game
you are flawed were flawed this whole
courtroom is flawed
yeah well we fuckin did an episode
and that's yeah that's what counts is
no one can say that we didn't
i hope everyone there was a great
tie someone who we didn't actually anything
interesting over there someone's that we didn't
do it paul was just looking at
his watch and i think yeah i
got it i got a mess it
was a message in what what did
it say that you're the best husband
in the whirl no it did not
oh here's what happened that is that
i got first i got an email
saying can you do this thing and
then i didn't respond to the email
then i got an email that said
following up can you do this thing
and i didn't respond to that email
and now i got a text that
said it didn't even acknowledge the emails
was like hey can you do to
save like like it's a new thought
i'm just wondering soon
and that's what the show fuck yourself
yeah
i hope you do it i hope
i do it too yeah you'd be
really good at it
i think it's like break his horse
ah
if you could be one animal what
would you be
one dozen dogs is good money
well god i would be
a teacup monkey
monkey huh interesting i'd be a teacup
giraffe
i mean there's two versions of every
animal right yeah yeah should be jimmy
welby sky hey well they not gonna
do it child ma
miniature horse knock onto satan na ganda
today saying we have magaluf satan brought
back guy that shot in france whose
ethanol sketches the model was look he's
gonna say the things save these things
you'll love the thing different setup he
will say the same worries every say
works it worked it worked like a
charm worked alright three m usa gmail
dot com if you would like to
send us a feature haha in pu
if you would like to leave us
a voicemail um follows essay on each
yeah um if you want to hear
ad-free versions you can go to stitcher
premium or cb world yeah paul
you only ate a banana yeah what
are you going to eat now two
bananas one banana two banana three banana
four are you a monkey i'm never
and you have to you have to
pay tell me monkeys have to say
i'm a monkey
you are a monkey um guys that's
gonna do it for us leave us
alone goodbye
uh